oh my god you you remind me of and I'm
thinking like okay you know who can it
be
you know DeNiro oh you know DiCaprio who
and that are you run remind me of Jet Li
of Jackie Chan are you playing this you
know not so educated or you're the
bougie black girl you know the one that
the one token black girls what I like to
call it I really gave up I thought you
know that I don't fit in any role I
don't fit fit into calc Asian role I
don't fit into Hispanic girl so I'm out
I did some traveling after I graduated
from college and then I came back to
Texas and my brother was murdered
yeah and in order to not i I've told the
story so many times and it's still
jarring because in order to not go
through a depression I just started
writing when I was a kid I loved Disney
movies and I always like it's cliche but
I always dreamed up being like the first
sort of you know princess that sounds so
funny I still had a dream come out again
like I said most of the ropes like hit
are you killing somebody but I really
don't get parts that are really
laid-back we're human we're gonna get
discouraged we're gonna beat ourselves
down at times but once again I know I am
destined to do something even if even if
it is it's become a great actor and you
know catch everybody on four corners of
the earth that's what I'm going to do so
I have to continue to go down my path
and my journey and then once again those
discouraging moments are the times where
I'm just feel like I can't do it but
those are the understand the moment you
find out who you are even more sometimes
in the breakdowns I'll see the
description first and then I'll say oh
but we're looking for this race and I'm
like oh man I was so right for that you
know because I'm not that stereotypical
like that girl so it's like oh this is
me this is me this
me oh but I can't just because of my
race I've considered myself a character
actor I would like to say addition for
the hero hero parts
I've onstage I've been angry a lot
we're not just your gangsters or your
mobsters your drug cartels or your
janitors were you know we're businessmen
we're lawyers were you know you know
working father in the fields you know
etc you know I just saw that Denzel
Washington wants to play James Bond and
that'd be great
I don't think that was gonna happen I
don't think it's gonna happen because
it's you just he's black guys and not
that guy mostly the characters that I go
for either it's comedy okay also I also
I did for like a for gangland I did I
did a cholo kind of ordeal I have a look
that I get stopped all the time and ask
don't I know you know but for some
reason I've been told by casting
directors consistently you have a look
that's very changeable and you can be an
every day woman even in regular life
outside of acting just wish that people
could get along that people could see
each other just past the skin because if
we all peeled our skin off we would just
be the same you couldn't tell at all who
we were but he didn't say you know this
is a wrap be more black you know he was
you know it's gonna feel a little bit
more kind of thing like you know things
like that well you you'll hear that you
never really say you don't be more
ethnic be more urban like I can't
believe you're Russian for instance cuz
nah blonde or I can't play there a
Ukrainian that they fall into that
specific look of blond characters I
can't play those and I was specifically
told that actually a lot of like student
films and low-budget movies always look
for the all-american type which is
either black or white and I'm neither so
it's like really hard to go out for that
or actually not hard I can't just go out
for that role
it's just like you know we need a white
long skinny female or we need you know
the typical ghetto black girl and it's
just like you only can do
you